my name is harriet m welsh and if i want  to be a writer i have to know everything  and to know everything i have to see  everything only way to see everything is  to be a spy  i just found a big story i need both of  you to help me oh we're in you just got  to know where to look  [Music]  for something this daring rules would  have to be broken if mr horatio finds  out you wandered off your future will be  in detention so you'd better cover for  me  doomed  [Music]  [Music]  you are leading not following like young  ladies are supposed to girls can lead  too  if a story leads you follow  i totally bit the biscuit on my mission  you've got to start looking out for  people besides yourself  they mess everything up maybe we can fix  it  [Music]  i must say oh bean your mustache looks  positively dashing thank you good sir it  took ever so long to grow  this is a revolution  i'm glad i'm not perfect i'd be bored to  death  [Music]